أولاً وقبل كل شيء ، رئيس الوزراء الياباني
فوميو كاشيدا آمن ، لكن كما
سترون ، كانت هناك بالتأكيد بعض
اللحظات المخيفة خلال خطوة الحملة يوم
السبت هنا في اليابان ،
يمكنك أن ترى من الفيديو أشخاصًا
يفرون من التجمع في واكاياما
في الجزء الجنوبي من اليابان وفقًا
لإذاعة NHK اليابانية الوطنية ،
ربما يكون الرجل الذي تم القبض عليه قد ألقى
قنبلة أنبوبية حديدية يضيفون عنصرًا ثانيًا
تمت مصادرته في مكان الحادث ولم ينفجر.
ذكرت وقوع انفجار ،
تعيد هذه القضية بالتأكيد ذكريات
اغتيال رئيس الوزراء السابق
شينزو آبي قبل أقل من عام
خلال خطاب ألقاه في الحملة الانتخابية
حدث مروع في دولة لا
ترتبط عادة بالعنف السياسي والعنف المسلح
مارك ستيوارت سي إن إن طوكيو.